in berlin bin ich verbunden mit gregor
gysi schon guten abend schön guten abend
herr gysi marxist tod nicht nur als
mensch sondern auch ideologisch warum so
er gefeiert werden naja ich glaube ja
dass im staatssozialismus kam max
missbraucht wurde
er war in wirklichkeit ein denker und
ein kämpfer für die befreiung der
menschen und nicht das gegenteil nicht
diktatur war sein ziel nicht ein mangel
an emanzipation an wirtschaftlicher
effizienz an freiheit und demokratie
sondern das gegenteil
und ich bin dafür dass wir karl marx
endlich befreien ein anderes verhältnis
zu ihm bekommt ich verstehe auch die
opferverbände nicht sie müssten
eigentlich auch für die befreiung von
karl marx sein weil er eben missbraucht
worden ist und die zweite befreiung die
wir brauchen er wurde eben aus
deutschland verbannt er konnte er seine
werke nur in london schreiben und ich
finde das müssten wir mal aufheben
wissen sie wir haben so ein
unnatürliches verhältnis immer noch zu
solchen größen der deutschen geschichte
die ja auch ein geist der weltgeschichte
bahn ganz unabhängig davon dass sie auch
missbraucht worden sind wofür aber kam
max nichts kann
aber ich verstehe immer noch nicht warum
es keinen staat gegeben hat der wenn er
sich auf karl marx berufen hat dann auch
einen tatsächlichen sozialismus in
seinem sinne umgesetzt hat das hat auch
die ddr ja nicht geschafft mainka max
hat ja zunächst analysiert den
kapitalismus die kapitalistische
produktionsweise sein wichtigstes werk
ist das kapital und nicht alles aber
vieles stimmt nach wie vor deshalb wird
er wieder gelesen deshalb ist er wieder
modern die krisen des kapitalismus die
zwangsläufig erscheint all das hat er
beschrieben und zwar sehr gut und sehr
klug und darauf kann man auch stolz sein
dass er das so gut und so klug
beschrieben hat und hinsichtlich der
künftigen gesellschaft hatte er nur eine
vision entwickelt und er ist ja zum teil
auch falsch zitiert worden sowohl in der
ddr als auch in der sowjetunion als auch
in china als auch in anderen ländern und
sie dürfen eines nicht vergessen es gab
nur drei versuche eines demokratischen
sozialismus alle drei versuche sind
militärisch kaputt gemacht worden
das war die pariser kommune das war
unter druck check der frühling in prag
also 1908
60 natural wacker und das war der
versuch von präsident allende in chile
dass es immer militärisch kaputt gemacht
worden
der staatssozialismus hat sich selbst
erledigt aber der demokratische hatte ja
noch keine chance und ich möchte dass
wir karl marx anders sehen er kann
nichts für seinen missbrauch und er war
ein großer denker und er ist ein großer
sohn unseres volkes und wir sollten
endlich lernt auch stolz zu sein und
wissen sie wenn kam achsen franzose
gewesen wäre gäbe es acht universitäten
mit seinem namen in deutschland gibt es
keine einzige mit seinem namen das muss
sich ändern
das müssen sie den universitäten dann
sagen aber die frage ist hier die frage
ist natürlich schon ob diese drei
versuche die sie geschildert haben dann
tatsächlich auch funktioniert hätten
denn es gibt ja durchaus kritiker die
sagen das funktioniert eigentlich gar
nicht was mag sich ausgedacht hat eine
frage noch zur ökonomischen schrift sie
haben sie ja eben angesprochen dem
kapital da ist immer wieder die rede
davon das ende des kapitalismus wird
vorausgesagt das gegenteil ist der fall
der kapitalismus lüth und hat alle
sozialistischen systeme überlebt also er
war ein großer geist das schließt aber
nicht aus dass man sich auch irren kann
er dachte er dass bald eine solche
revolution kommt die ist nicht gekommen
aber ich glaube nicht dass der
kapitalismus die letzte antwort der
geschichte ist schauen sich die krisen
an er neigt dazu immer in immer weniger
händen den reichtum zu konzentrieren und
die armut zu verbreiten das kann gar
nicht gut gehen er kriegt die
ökologische nachhaltigkeit nicht hin ich
sage nur stichwort klimawandel aber das
schlimmste ist dass er kriege nicht
verhindert das geht immer um den kampf
um ressourcen und es wird an kriegen zu
viel verdient ich weiß auch was der
kapitalismus kann die linke darf nie den
fehler begehen das zu übersehen
effiziente wirtschaft top wissenschaft
und forschung gute kunst und kultur etc
er kann demokratisch sein aber er muss
nicht demokratisch sein dass alles sehe
ich wenn wir das aber überwinden was
wirklich schädlich ist nämlich diese
unvorstellbare soziale ungerechtigkeit
hunger elend die kriege und vor allen
dingen auch dann endlich eine
ökologische nachhaltigkeit herstellen
und letztlich geht es doch um ein ziel
wir brauchen die emanzipation
um des menschen die hat der
staatssozialismus nicht erreicht aber
der kapitalismus erreicht sie auch nicht
und insofern sie haben recht den
demokratischen sozialismus hat es noch
nicht gegeben
aber das für den kapitalismus in dieser
form zumindest teilweise überwinden
müssen
das scheint mir festzustehen ob ich das
noch erlebe und sie weiß ich nicht aber
ich glaube die menschheit entwickelt
sich weiter aber diese dieser
dialektisches pro verdienter die rede
ist der dann ins paradies auf erden für
der hat noch nie funktioniert
letztendlich scheitert er doch immer am
menschen selber und am menschenbild das
stimmt man darf kein falsches
menschenbild haben man darf uns nicht
idealisieren wir sind alle irgendwie
egoistisch etc
das alles hat folgen das war auch ein
fehler dass die linken oft den menschen
versucht haben zu idealisieren oder
seien nach seiner in nach ihren
vorstellungen zu gestalten da haben sie
recht
aber auf der anderen seite gibt es immer
eine entwicklung eine tube utopie kann
man nie erreichen da haben sie recht
aber man kann sich hier annähernd
schauen sie sich doch mal die
entwicklung an in meinem leben
drei große veränderungen die
gleichstellung der geschlechter ist
immer noch nicht da aber wenn ich mal
davon ausgehen wie die 1950 aussah das
ist doch eine enorme entwicklung als ich
ein kind war wurden erwachsene männer
die sich liebt noch eingesperrt heute
dürfen sie die ehe mit dem land
erschließen die küche damals war nur
national
heute haben wir eine internationale
küche wissen sie ich möchte auch dass
wir sehen es gibt fortschritt und dann
haben wir eben auch rückschritt die
kriege sind wieder scheinbar
selbstverständlich die armut nimmt zu
und dagegen gibt es doch die vernunft
des menschen auf die ich letztlich
setzte obwohl ich ihnen nicht
idealisieren
und ich weiß dass es visionen gibt die
man nie erreicht aber man kann sich ihn
annähern mehr emanzipation des menschen
mehr demokratie mehr sozialer
gerechtigkeit
es lohnt sich doch dafür zu kämpfen
sonst könnten wir noch alle einfach die
hände in die hosentaschen stecken und
sagen es ändert sich sowieso nicht wir
machen nichts mehr
das geht nicht das geht nicht gregor
gysi eine letzte frage noch die freiheit
des menschen ist bei karl marx in den
schriften von ganz ganz besonderer
bedeutung wie passt es zusammen dass ein
totalitäres regime wie in china genau
sich auf ihn beruft ja das passt ist
sofern zusammen ich war ja in china vor
anderthalb
jahren dann habe ich denen gesagt er
macht eine kapitalistische
marktwirtschaft haben sie zu mir gesagt
ja weil wir keine marx verstanden haben
da sage ich wieso jamaika max gesagt hat
die aufgabe des kapitalismus ist die
industrialisierung also braucht man eine
kapitalistische marktwirtschaft damit
wir die industrialisierung hinbekommen
war übrigens ein schwerer irrtum von
leni und da habe ich gesagt ja aber kam
max hat nicht geschrieben dass darüber
ein diktatorischer überbau sein muss
sondern mehr demokratie mehr freiheit c3
und dann wissen sie natürlich in den
antworten aus das ganze problem ist im
kommunistischen manifest haben friedrich
engels und karl marx einen ganz
wichtigen satz geschrieben
sie wollen eine klassenlose gesellschaft
ohne unterdrückung ohne ausbeutung in
der die freiheit des einzelnen die
bedingung und voraussetzung der freiheit
aller ist und darauf könnte man sich
doch verständigen und dann wurde das in
der ddr zum teil falsch zitiert wurde
mir gesagt die freiheit aller ist die
voraussetzung für die freiheit des
einzelnen
da konnte man sagen daher auf der welt
noch viele menschen nicht frei sind muss
auch der einzelnen der ddr noch warten
dann haben wir aber festgestellt dass
das ein falsches zitat ist und damit
muss man leute finde ich konfrontieren
die sich auf ihn berufen bist du
wirklich für die freiheit des einzelnen
aus als voraussetzung der freiheit aller
und wenn man das macht finde ich müsste
die zustimmen und größer werden auch bei
denen die unter dem staatssozialismus
gelitten haben denn das macht auch
deutlich dass canucks etwas anderes
wollte übrigens wenn ich das noch kurz
sagen darf in der bundesrepublik gab es
auch im ein falsches zitat von karl marx
und zwar wurde immer behauptet er hätte
gesagt religion ist opium für das volk
hat er nicht er hat geschrieben religion
ist opium des volkes der unterschied für
das volk heißt religion wird ihm
operiert und opium des volkes heißt das
versucht sich die religion in der
hoffnung dass es ihm im jenseits besser
geht ganz unterschiedliche aussagen also
wir müssen lernen korrekt zu werden
gerade was kann max betrifft dann bin
ich ganz herzlich bedankt dafür dass sie
das jetzt korrekt dargestellt haben wir
glaube ich könnte das noch eine reihe
von minuten weiterführen dankeschön
gregor gysi nach berlin wünsche ihnen
auch alles gute